Arena uh a great game for you uh this
was not easy against a player that you
know oh so well one of your Rivals for
many many years than us uh through
today's
game yeah well um of course I was kind
of uh baffled by what was going on in
the opening um because she actually she
played the same line against me that she
played at the Karen's cup and I took on
C5 but that can't really have been a big
surprise to her because I did that uh
like less than a month ago against hkaa
in the Tata steel rapid um and then but
but she seemed like kind of not so sure
about what to do so that that was the
surprising part she really spent a lot
of time um but really I hadn't done
anything surprising um so she took the
pawn on B2 of course it's risky I didn't
know exactly why it was um like bad I
mean I just know white has a lot of play
for this kind of Pawn and really the
very tough moment for me came like on
this move I spent like what like half an
hour over here um on Knight G5 right
because first of all I completely did
not accept Castle expect castles right
when I played Knight G5 I thought she'd
play Knight
E5 um at least that was the move that
worried me right and yeah and the thing
is that um like if I go Bishop B3 here
which was sort of my first instinct um I
had some issues with Bishop G4 right and
like rook d8 and because I'm not castled
uh Knight D3 is a problem
so why did I ultimately go for Knight G5
because I I kind of figured out that on
Knight E5 I can just castle and I can
afford to give up my light squared
bishop and this took me a while to
really come to because you know giving
up that Bishop is not an easy decision
so you really have to evaluate this
position with the Bishops of opposite
color and I thought on castles there's
Bishop C5 and then once I kind of saw
those ideas um I was feeling pretty
confident that I would have um like what
I wanted in this position but this was
like for sure you know the most
difficult moments of the game for me
because I thought if I castled instead
of Knight G5 and she castles I mean I
wasn't so sure you know what was going
on with my initiative there yeah and it
does seem like it dissipates after uh
this couple of castles but Knight to G5
very forceful very precise move I have
to say and uh after that where did you
feel like you're finally in full control
of your advantage because you did get
the advantage but it still wasn't that
easy
oh yeah I mean when I got the two
Bishops against the two knights
obviously I thought I I was very happy
sort of in the beginning but then I
realized okay there's actually a lot of
work here I think the move H4 obviously
won me the game um it turned out to be a
lot trickier than I expected I mean the
whole point of H4 is actually to have
Bishop G5 ideas um but I guess I don't
know I guess she just I don't know
missed that or something because
otherwise like why would I weaken the
pawn that much why would I put it to H4
right right right but um you know yeah
so she kind kind of stepped right into
the whole point of age four and then you
know once you win the exchange it's easy
but I mean other than that I mean it was
still it was still going to be a game
but it's certainly kind of like
unpleasant for black even before she she
blenders The
Exchange well Arena congratulations an
important victory for you uh very good
victory for you because there are two
ladies that are also scoring a lot of
points that is uh beim who still has to
win her game but it seems like she's
winning that one and Karissa take us
about these Dynamics right now in the
tournament with you three not
necessarily running away with the event
but definitely showing that you are the
top favorites to win
it yeah I mean I'm just kind of playing
my tournaments especially because I
cross path with Karissa in round one so
that like big matchup came so early and
then you know we're just playing our own
tournaments um you know I still have
beum left to play but there's still
there's just so many games still left
that you know I feel like yeah
everything is going fine absolutely guys
any questions for no just our congrat
ulations Arena as we're in this round
after the rest day and the players came
with so much vim and vigor we've seen a
large number of decisive games already
and